كنيسه الاسرائيليه الثقه للحكومه الجديده
برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو باغلبيه 63 عضوا
من حزب الليكود الحاكم واحزاب اقصى اليمين
من الصهيونيه الدينيه واحزاب المتزامتين
اليهود بينما عرضه 55
الجديد قد قدم للكنيست وثيقه الخطوط
العريضه لحكومه المقبله ومن ابرزها ابرز
بنودها ما وصف باحقيه اليهود في كامل
اراضي فلسطين التاريخيه وتعزيز الاستيطان
وتوسيعه في الضفه والجولان
وكنانه الياهو قد قال ان المهمه الاولى
التي تعتزم حكومته وانجازها هي احباط
مساعد ايران لانتاج سلاح النووي وانه
ستتبع هذا الهدف تطوير البناء تحتيه
ومعالجته غلاء المعيشه وتحسينه مستوى
التعليم
باسره مهمتنا الثانيه تطوير البنا التحتيه
للدوله وانشاء قطار سريعا يصل الشمال
بالجنوب لاحداث ثوره في هذا المجال مصرون
على معالجه غلاء المعيشه والسكن وتحسين
مستوى التعليم لكل طبقات المجتمع
وما بقى الكنيست ظاهره اسرائيليون
بالتزامن مع جلسه منح الثقه لحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده ويحتجل
المتظاهرون على ما ينصفونه بتشكيل الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا دينيا وسياسيا واجتماعيا منذ
اقامته اسرائيل ويتهم المحتجون نتنياهو
بالسعي للبقاء في السلطه لحمايه نفسه من
البحر في قضايا الفساد بها
القدس مراسله الجزيره نجوان صبري نجوان
اذا تم منح الثقه ولكن هل هذه الاغلبيه
مريحه بالنسبه لتنياهو لتنفيذ برنامجه
السياسي
هي اغلبيه مريحه لنتنياهو وفقا لقوانين
الاسرائيليه بمعنى ان لديه الاغلبيه
النيابيه التي فاز بها في الانتخابات او
فاز بها معسكره في الانتخابات الاخيره من
نائبا وهو الذي يشكل حاليا لاتلاف الحكومي
الجديد وهكذا مر هذا القانون او منح الثقه
وتنصيب الحكومه الجديده باغلبيه من ثلاثه
وستين نائبا في الكنيسه دائما ستكون
المعارضه اقل من هذا العدد عليه يسهل على
نتنياهو واعضاء لائتلاف الحكومي الجديد ان
يمرر قوانين باغلبيه سواء كانت قوانين
حكومه او قوانين اخرى تتعلق بمشاريع في
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي لكن السؤال هو جمال هل
سيتمكن نتنياهو والاعضاء في هذا الائتلاف
الجديد
المشكل من اقصى احزاب اليمين المتطرف اح
الصهيونيه الدينيه واحزاب المتدينين
المتزمين اليهود سواء كان من حركه شاس
لليهود المتزمطين الشرقين او من يهدودها
ترى همم اليهود المتدينين الغربيين هل سوف
يتمكنون بالفعل من تمرير ما يريدون همم
سواء كان توجهات سياسيه او دينيه
وهناك سؤال يعني يطرح في هذا السياق من
جهه قد يقومون باستغلال هذه المناصب
الوزاريه وتشريع قوانين تماس تحديدا
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه هذا من جهه ولكن من
جهه اخرى نتنياهو يعلم اليوم ان الاعين
مفتوحه عليه بشكل كبير محليا ودوليا بسبب
هذه الحكومه الموصوفه بانها الحكومه
الاكثر تطرفا وبانه وافق ورضا
لشروط معينه حددها شركاؤه في هذا الائتلاف
من اجل البقاء في السلطه وحمايه نفسه
المحاكمه التي يخضع لها نتنياهو الهدف
الرئيسي لنتنياهو في الفتره القريبه
المقبله هو سن قانون يعرف بالقانون
الفرنسي وهو لمنع محاكمه رئيس حكومه في
اسرائيل اثناء ولايته اذا استطاع تمرير
هذا القانون ربما ستصبح المواجهه بينه
وبين شركائه في الائتلاف الحكومي اصعب لكن
حاليا هدفه تمرير هذا القانون والحفاظ على
هذا الائتلاف في هذه المرحله الى حين
بالفعل يستطيع تحقيق تحصين نفسه من
المحاكمه ولكن من جهه اخرى راينا كيف انه
بحسب وصف الاسرائيليين دفع اثمان باهظه
لقاء تشكيل هذه الحكومه والعوده الى
السلطه همم جمال شكرا
مراسله الجزيره متحدثا الينا من القدس
شكرا